non-minimalists
when the amount of your belongings is
completely overwhelming
how and where do you even start
here's my pithy answer maybe we could
talk about it ryan
the why is the starting point the how
is the finish line okay so
i the question has a win in it it has a
how
and it has a wear right
but the why is the actual starting line
now
i think you have a piece of the y here
you're overwhelmed
but i think right now you're only
intellectually overwhelmed
yeah and that's still overwhelming and
so by being intellectually overwhelmed
there's a lot of shoulds what you're
telling yourself is i should
simplify i should let go letting go
isn't prescriptive
right right if you go outside ryan and
you pick up a
a thorny cactus there's like it's laying
on the ground you pick it up
and it's hurting you mm-hmm you don't
need the how to
let go of the cactus right you
understand
viscerally that you must
let go and you simply drop it not out of
prescription no one told you
ryan you have to drop that cactus no no
that wasn't that wasn't required
but of course the how to ryan we can we
can talk about some of the how-to things
sure about how how to start or or when
to start
where to start but always start with the
why how might my life be better with
less without this item understanding
that deeply and viscerally
the letting go becomes so much easier
yeah
oh man yeah it's it's interesting people
are they're just looking for the how to
because they are so over overwhelmed so
they want the recipe it's like you know
if i wanted to bake a cake
i would look for the recipe sure where's
the recipe um
however two things if it was my first
cake
that i was baking i'm probably going to
screw it up so even if i had the recipe
i'm not going to do it correctly
and then let's say i did it perfectly i
might not that might not be my favorite
flavor of cake
right now i just want to eat cake can we
extend this analogy a little bit farther
sure ryan because i
i think it's great is that if you're
truly
hungry the you're not even going to need
the recipe for cake you're going to find
a way to
nourish yourself the cake is is you know
and of course the icing on the cake as
as we say right
it's it it's everything else after we've
we've we've done what we need to do
anyway i'm sure you've got some of the
pithy for us
yeah my pithy answer is this a life
without boundaries is a life without
peace
so james here's the thing is
you're overwhelmed because you haven't
set up the appropriate boundaries
so you know once you get past the why
once you answer that question how might
your life be better with less
you have to get clear on what you're
what on what you want your life to look
like so going back to the minimalist
rule book that'd be a great place to
start james
you can uh adapt for your life
those rules you can you can edit them a
little bit
um the rules that we have laid out it's
for josh and i it's not for you per se
if you take all of our rules up and
you're like these are the perfect rules
for me also great that's
outstanding you're not going to get a
certificate or anything
but the key is is like you have to set
up some boundaries and then
here's the third and most important part
i feel is you got to take action
if you don't take the action james
doesn't matter what
what you know self-help book you read
you have to take action and i think
going back to the baking the cake
analogy
people are scared to start because
they're scared of failing
they're scared of it not working the way
that they intended it to
and yeah i guess you know that's my way
of just giving james or anyone else out
there permission
to screw it up start and screw up and
learn from it and then start again
the cake actually really highlights that
because no one's really afraid of baking
a cake
right but when it becomes these higher
stake items like higher stakes items
like letting go of your stuff
or ending a relationship or dealing with
sentimental items i mean i think about
that is getting rid of some of my mom's
stuff
that produced initially a lot of anxiety
and stress and and overwhelm in me and
james is talking about
how overwhelming this process is baking
a cake generally isn't
overwhelming well why isn't it
overwhelming it would be if you had
never heard of cake before
yeah and you had never been in a kitchen
before sure
if you're some tribal person who's just
brought into a kitchen and
you're going to be overwhelmed but
it it quickly becomes not overwhelming
because
there is a recipe and the recipe isn't
just the ingredients there's a
sequence of events there as well and so
things like the minimalist rule book
we give you a recipe and you can adjust
it
for your own taste
you